[Music]
hey what's up guys my name's samuel
leeds and welcome back to another
winners on a wednesday interview i'm sat
here with my very good friend jamie
hicks jeremy great to see you again
thank you very much for having me on
again now jamie has become a not a
property millionaire jamie's become a
millionaire through investing in
property in the last two years you came
on winners on a wednesday exactly a year
ago yeah and at that point wherever you
are about then you're just financially
free
financially independent i would say yes
i'd replace my income um but we were
kind of working towards replacing my
wife's income as well so she can come on
board with a business since then you've
bought so many houses you can't even
count
no because
i remember one of your events somebody
asked you the question and you were kind
of like so ask me what question how many
houses have you got how many you've got
and you kind of didn't answer with a
specific number yeah and some people
people hate they're like oh you didn't
answer how can you not know and it's
like well
but now i understand because you've got
different stages of different projects
some you sell to you know to capital
raise yeah some you know just kind of
sit within the within the portfolio so
yeah i understand now like you might be
developing some you might have a bit
like you've got like a big commercial
unit where you've split the titles does
that count as one does that count as six
you've just sold some you've got a piece
of land where you're trying to build
what does that so but however yours you
came up to me yesterday at the brighton
property millionaire intensive and what
was the reason that you came down to the
event so i wanted to come to the event
just to say thank you really just to say
thank you for you know putting me in the
position i'm in i'm now a millionaire
another i want to touch on a millionaire
but where people think you're a
millionaire like all of my money is out
working hard yes it's all tied up in
property so you know
as far as having hundreds of thousands
in the bank that's not the case with me
all of that is out working hard but
what's the difference between a property
millionaire and a millionaire
well a property millionaire will own a
million payments with a property and uh
a millionaire if you sold everything
there's the the net i make left is seven
figures right so a property millionaire
might have ten houses worth a grand but
their
net worth might only be 250 grand
because they've got mortgages your net
worth is now a million pounds just over
there just over respect by the way and
you came down to the property
millionaire yesterday probably intensive
just to say thank you i'm a millionaire
thank you very much for you know for the
training the guidance the mentorship um
you know i've reached out a few times to
you
and you really helped
um the academy the support from the
members the support from you know
the trainers it's been fantastic
um
you know like i haven't really been
hanging on anyone's coattails or bugging
people
do what it says on the tin do what the
training asks you to do or you know
guide you to do and then when you get
stumped kind of yeah ask for support and
that's what what i've done
you said tell everyone what you do so i
did i got the car sign written um you
know attended local events
spread the word as much as like as i
could
being open really we're looking for you
know we're looking to buy we're also
looking for investors
but yeah right across the board it was
kind of tell everyone what you do
the first deal actually come from my
left
we spoke about it on the last win as we
left i left the course went and spoke to
a local successful
investor and that kind of created my
that come up with my first year we had
dinner with tonight as well nice better
networking yeah we had dinner tonight
was interesting as well about about your
story so we we met yesterday and you
told me i've got this house this house
this house i've done this deal i've
pulled all my money out so i said to you
can we go around them and you literally
printed off a list
of every property that you own and every
property that you've been involved with
all the joint ventures and it was a big
list
i was looking at oh my goodness i said
well how long was it going to take to
get around and you're like well it might
take a day or two so i said well let's
go around as many as we can we've been
together for the last six hours we've
had the dinner but we've been viewing
properties back to back to back-to-back
you've literally been saying this is
what i did with this one we couldn't go
inside because they're all tenanted but
how you've grown such a large property
portfolio in two years is absolutely
impressive you've must have worked your
ass off the last couple of years i have
but i've also um
added to the team as well with people
who i trust yeah so um
we've got a full-time source from a
property manager chris on board uh we've
got a small build team down in the
clinically that we you know we
constantly keep keep busy um i've got
sadie looks after the
the social media side of it the traffic
so at first when i started out
it's all you you're doing everything you
do you know one even to the point where
you know i was painting walls
um
but now
you realize you can't and to scale like
you said from the off you need to
systemize as much as you can yes and
pull in support where you do so
everyone's got their own specific roles
we've all got our own roles within the
business
which that has really helped us scale
and take on more projects i think from a
sourcing point of view we've got six
live projects on which is not a
fantastic i mean but they're sourced
and we're doing the project management
for the refurbs as well so
i couldn't do that on my own like we've
been we've been touring today
across the you know this this side of
the portfolio
i know chris has been daniel and nephew
doing viewings
you know keeping that keeping the
pipeline full of such and negotiating
freeholds and and all sorts so she had
to systemize and to
recognize when you kind of maxed out on
what you can do
so if you do it all yourself then i i
believe that'll stifle your growth yeah
um it is an investment from the business
to
to pay wages but it's definitely
definitely helped now when we last spoke
a year ago you had left your high-paying
job in fact you left your job just after
joining the academy i believe yeah what
happened there how did you come to the
realization and the decision of because
your job was you weren't working at
mcdonald's you weren't a factory worker
you were had a quite a serious position
what were you doing and why did you
decide to leave so i was on a kind of a
leadership stroke management career path
that was kind of laid out in front of me
um and like i spoke about before i you
know it wasn't i enjoyed it but it kind
of there was a cap on what i could do
and what i could achieve personally so i
made the decision that
i was going to go into property but in
order for that to that to happen i had
to kind of go all out and go for it
right from the off now we did cause some
problems
when i'm trying to refinance because you
know i didn't have any businesses i
didn't have any any rentals at all
so when i kind of made myself unemployed
on paper yeah
that's when i needed my you know that's
what i needed a good broker as such so
right i was going to ask how did you get
around that problem because trying to
get a mortgage on all of these property
investments with no income so i mean i
did have savings i had a small amount of
savings and i kind of
linked with the right people i linked
with you know i built a power team yeah
because listen they're good good broker
good accountant you know all of these
things good mentors all of these these
kind of pieces of the jigsaw were put in
place
because
i i kind of say i know
a little bit a lot yeah if i make you
know i kind of know a little bit about
a little bit of this a little bit but
then i just went to the experts i just
went with the guys who could who could
help me you know get the end result that
i that i needed just to move forward so
a lot of people on winners on a
wednesday a lot of people on the academy
um
when they come on the academy they've
got nothing their net worth is zero
they've got no savings you weren't in
that situation you didn't have lots of
cash in the bank
but when we first spoke and when you
joined the academy you did have a house
that you owned
what was your financial situation when
you first went into property and joined
the academy and what happened and how
did you reshape your thinking towards
philosophies around investing
so the first the first kind of event
that the kickstarted it was um an uplift
in my house
due to the bridge though going my house
went up in value i decided to use that
opportunity with some savings
to
raise some capital i set aside a budget
for training and then i knew i kind of
had a pot of money then for
for purchasing
so that's what happened i refinanced
pulled some money out i spent some money
on training i spent some money you know
elsewhere as well with a few you know
few other mentors few other
events that i attended
but kind of when i come to the academy i
come to the crash course i'd already
decided i'd already seen your content
online on youtube
and yeah kind of knew that you offered
an end to end lots of different
strategies and also what appealed to me
as well was was kind of the business
support that was offered at the end as
well and you know the social media kind
of marketing side of it yeah sure that
was dropped in at the at the back end of
it which
again really supported the growth of the
business afterwards
so you were literally a situation
whereby you had a decent job you had a
nice little house you were paying down
the mortgage had a little bit of savings
very normal yeah how old are you now i'm
39 so you were about 37 yeah
beautiful wife couple of kids kind of
the normal life right but but presumably
you realized if you carry on doing what
you're doing if you carry on working a
job paying down the mortgage number one
you're going to work until you're in
your 60s number two is you're not going
to be able to leave generational wealth
for your kids
that was it so i mean
in the position i was in we went through
a lot of changes within the business
which meant unfortunately some people
were you know made redundant and i kind
of thought well maybe one day that's me
right and that could be me so i wanted
to come up with um generational wealth
within property so i could kind of leave
a legacy with my kids but also
don't have the worry as if if something
happens to me whether you know
i become incapacitated for whatever
reason i can't work
then as the main bread winner for the
house
that's us we're done you know we we then
can you know live the life we want to
live
but um you know seeing a different light
seeing a different way to earn a
steady income
but like now with you know with the team
i've got in place if i step away
or you know
something happens then that still ticks
along yeah and there is a long-term plan
to uh you know bring the bring the kids
into the business
with trusts and things like that and you
know bringing them in as be shareholders
so yeah nice and i want to talk a little
bit more about some of that stuff do you
think that having a job
is perhaps a little bit riskier than
people think because when most people
think of having a job they think of
security what do you think about that
um at first having a job was the main
thing that obviously we're taught right
away from the beginning so get a job i
think
if you've got
one source of income and it's your job
then you're far more at risk than you
than you think because ultimately if you
work for a big corporation then they're
gonna have a restructure for whatever
reason or if you um again you become ill
for whatever reason and you can't work
then you're kind of in a risky risky
position yeah in my in my opinion now so
so yeah that's kind of the all these all
these things are going through your head
and then you it's a mass it was a
massive risk it felt so for three you
know for three months waking up
it's a different motivation because
usually you know when your pay pack is
going to come
but then
that's kind of how the system wants it
to be they want you to have that regular
pay packet just enough just enough to
live
versus then being you know a business
owner
where there's really no limit on what
you can earn so that's good question are
you in a better position now financially
than you were two years ago
yes massively a little bit
monthly not not tremendously um
different because we've had to replace
two wages yeah uh and there is that
there is a kind of a
there is a as a as a slightly lifestyle
similar lifestyle because this is what
we just say this is really interesting
point
you're now a millionaire some people
might think you're a millionaire
you have
really fancy cars you got loads of money
in the bank you've paid her for your
debts
actually you've got more debt now
than you had two years ago yes you've
probably got less money in the bank now
than you did two years ago i hope
yes because it's always working right so
there's a real interesting shift here
with for people's philosophy because
when people are trying to get rich
you're now most people would probably
consider you rich you're a millionaire
um not super rich but but you you've
done well
but
most people think to get rich you want
to pay off your debts you want to put
money in the bank
you want nice fast cars you've not got
any of those things no so what's the
what's the goal then what was you've
achieved a lot and you've got a lot more
to go but you're a millionaire so what's
the lesson in that
i suppose the lesson is
you can you you kind of can live a
different life with a different mindset
so if your mindset is slightly different
to
to thinking i don't mind i've got this
debt in the background but the assets
take away the debt
and you also know your income like one
of the things you said obviously was
find out your your figure your bottom
figure that you need to earn permanently
yep to come out and we did and you know
we were frugal with that we brought it
right down
um we achieved that and now it was kind
of like okay what about financially free
what does that number look like so we
can kind of live so it's been it's been
massive sacrifice for like
two and a half years really
but um it's just the lifestyle
how did you
how did you
come to the decision about your wife
leaving work
uh it was
it was because i couldn't do it all
myself right i couldn't do you know i
couldn't yes there's a certain way of
systemizing but you kind of need to be
in a few different places at the same
time you kind of sometimes for myself
been a situation where my wife's left
work as well
sometimes you're hiring staff and you're
thinking man my wife's working in the
job maybe making two three four grand a
month whatever
i'm hiring staff i'm needing it just
makes sense to bring my wife in on the
business absolutely so
i mean i i'm sure i'm sure she'll back
me up and say it that she's learning as
well as well as i'm learning but also
the the team that we've brought on
um
they're all we're all learning at the
same time we're all kind of growing
together yeah so
i under all the answers
i
know of the guy who's between them but i
definitely know i could pick up a phone
and find out the answers regardless of
what we're talking about whether it's
splitting titles whether it's raising
finance marketing you know that's we're
all kind of on a journey together so
yeah that's the great thing about it is
we
we kind of we sit down we've got a
routine we sit down in the morning
what's the plan for the day etc yeah
and we've split the rules and that's the
main thing you know you don't kind of
cross over into there as long as the
roles are clear and concise between each
one of you and then you kind of review
it on a weekly basis roles and
responsibilities being super clear
rather than being muddled around who's
supposed to be doing what how many
members of staff do you have now
um
there's there's three
my three
me and my wife so
there's kind of five of us working
towards the same thing when you came on
winners on a wednesday a year ago you'd
quit your job your wife was still
working and you didn't have any
employees
so now you've scaled and you've
systemized things your portfolio's
exploded you've bought a whole bunch
more houses what's been the what would
you say is the lesson
about scaling a portfolio
um
realizing when you need help
realizing when you're kind of maxed out
clear rules and responsibilities
and i'll say it as it is identifying the
bullshitters yeah
and what i mean by that is people that
kind of come into your circle that are
toxic and people that
kind of
they [ __ ] you from the off
an example being from the source inside
of it i'll take a call from somebody
we'll have a chat they've got x amount
of money
we deliver a deal that satisfies the
original needs
and
they kind of they're reversing back out
of it right because at the start they
didn't they didn't tell you the truth
yeah so i remember having this
conversation with you about a year and a
half ago where i was saying to you take
money up front yeah do you remember this
on the remember this conversation we had
i was saying when you got when you've
got an investor that wants to buy a deal
we are and again us
sometimes
what did the one chap say to me he said
i have to live with you ten years before
i give you two grand
but the but a scenario there was he
drove all the way up from south to view
one property
in in wales and then drove home and i
kind of said to him well what you're
paying for is the service of we're on
the ground and we're viewing
10 times more than that yeah
weekly
so
that's kind of for me it was the clear
roles responsibilities
recognizing when you're mac state and
what you can do bringing people on board
that you trust yes and we've got your
back
and also making sure that
everyone's happy you know everyone's on
the same wavelength that's that's kind
of what's really helped the business
grow because if i was still doing it on
my own then
half of this wouldn't be possible are
you still grinding really really hard or
are you now no no as in you know it kind
of becomes a way of life yeah like there
is no alarm
clock on to get up and then that's what
time i clock off right it's kind of just
and now so
you do what you want as such but there's
also i've got my roles and
responsibilities it's kind of like i
feel like as a business owner it's more
lifestyle so rather than it being i work
925 you might be able to have a day off
whenever you feel like it lying
go out like i just said to you yesterday
can i come out tomorrow you went like oh
i've got stefan yeah man sure come on
out see there's freedom but also you've
still got this underlying just living
and breathing work and business you've
got to love it if you don't love it
you're not you're not going to do well
100 i mean
the one thing that you i've been taught
from early age is you've got a graft and
you're passing that on to the children
so
if you have if you don't want the graft
and you just want to kick back on the
beach from day one then
i don't think
you're going to be successful so
i'm always going to work
i can't see me ever doing zero hours
work a week yeah um
but more it'll be more of a handing over
of the ship
to the boys
rather than just going right bang i'm
done can anybody become a millionaire
or do you take a very rare breed of
person
i think anyone could become a
millionaire why do you say that
because this there's opportunities out
there
there's vast opportunities out there not
just in property you know you'll see all
the
the different ways you can earn money i
just think you need commitment and
dedication to your one course that you
choose yeah so you just choose what you
want to do stick to it
that vehicle you choose to yeah to make
money in there needs to be the ability
to become a millionaire what do you
think about this because i've been
hung up on instagram recently by saying
a few things i've been interested in
your take on it one of the things i said
on instagram is i said i think side
hustles are for losers
side hustle meaning people that have a
side hustle if you don't treat something
as a business and focus on it you're
never going to get results if you see it
as a side hustle you'll get side hustle
results
yeah i think just on like if it's a side
i think hobbies
over time could become your main
business if you love if you if that's
your passion but um
you get i think you get blink i get a
lot of like right bitcoins over there
yeah stocks and shares are over there i
just stay focused really and there's
nothing wrong with doing different
things but i personally think you need
to choose what's your main source of
income good a bit and until you've got
that succeed then if you're trying a bit
of this and then when it gets tough
trying a bit of this and then it gets
tough trying a bit of this looking for
that shiny penny looking for that magic
bullet there isn't one the only magic
bullet is you
yeah there's but don't get me wrong this
is this is
you know this has not been an easy path
because
for
18 20 years i knew when the money was
going to hit the bank on a monthly basis
so that is kind of if that's your if
that's your choice and you're happy with
that but it comes with risks
yeah and and it's been a feast and
famine
kind of roller coaster really as you're
setting up until your your monthly
income gets to a point where you're like
right i'm okay yeah but even then the
refinances if there's a delay with
refinances and you've got things lined
up right then obviously there's a bit of
a snowball and you've got to fill that
gap yeah so i think it's really
important as well
you know we teach on the academy we
teach fast pound slow pound active
income passive income you've built a big
empire of slow pound
longevity wealth
a lot of what we teach on the academy is
fast pound rent to rent steel sourcing
quick money quick money quick money put
that quick money into slow money
you focus more on the slow pound it's
taken you a couple of years but you've
done super well
what do you think what do you think
about some of the other strategies that
you've not done so much like rent to
rent something you've not really done
that at all deal sourcing you do a
little bit but on a very small scale
what do you think about some of these
fast pounds skills and why did you
choose to go more than the slow route
building building an empire as opposed
to making some quick money
i think because from the offset i kind
of knew that
i wanted to pass it on in the future but
also i also did have a little bit of
cash yeah not a tremendous amount and i
knew i had a i had a
i kind of had a one-time pot that i seen
it at that moment in time an opportunity
life was in the right place i had that
part to use and that was the strategy i
went for
rent to rent if you haven't got that pot
and you haven't got um access to capital
in the beginning
then yes i i see rent to rent as a great
source of replacing your income yeah um
but i kind of wasn't in that position at
the start i knew i had a start i had
enough to start
so if you just started out with nothing
you would have then probably implemented
rent to rents and maybe even deal
sourcing a bit more i would have gone
after the deal so there's no excuses if
you've got no money you can just do some
of the fast pound stuff to begin with
and as long as you invest that then
you know or a portion of it into the brr
then i don't think you can go wrong so
you refinance your house get a part of
money
in in just summary terms how do you turn
a small pot of money into a massive
multi-million pound portfolio how do you
take a small pot of money and recycle it
over and over and over again so we we
kind of looked for problems really we
fixed the problems within the properties
or the deal
and then added value so we kind of look
for the really bad the worst taste we
possibly can find in any street it
doesn't it kind of doesn't matter if the
deal stacks we then come in and add
value yeah and then when we refinance
the uplift
um and value kind of you start you you
get your money back you know whatever
you bring and in some instances we we've
actually made money not just broke even
we've made money but then there's other
deals where we've left a little bit in
so what you're talking about is
to to fix the property up and flip it
normally you buy it you push the value
up you refurb it then you sell it you
make a profit you're choosing to leave
use that profit as the deposit in the
property so you're buying the house
you're fixing it up you're refinancing
it and the money that you're putting out
is tax-free you're paying back your
initial you're paying yourself back or
you're bridging company back you're left
with a house that's effectively a no
money down deal in some cases you leave
a little bit in some cases you get a
free house and you have a bit of money
in your pocket so that's your strategy
to do that you need to find problem
properties
now what kind of problems have you been
solving the last year then so we've been
looking for things like absent
freeholders what does that mean um so
where the the owner of the land is
missing and it kind of potentially would
would stop a refinance we've been
finding them guys and girls how'd you
put them down
um we've we've hired a private detective
we've um over there with the sunglasses
in the newspapers looking around
so a private detective was when we used
we used um
facebook social media contacted the name
because offlane registry you've got
basic details of that individual um you
know you've got the name you just search
like crazy around the area and then you
kind of follow the trail then knock on
the doors the neighbors they give you
some information so talk me through this
and say so you've got an absent
freeholder in that situation what
generically happens to that property
well
we
if if we don't find it then you know the
freeholder might pass away and it then
drops down to the to the next next in
line send or wherever that person is and
then we would go to them
um but in this case we found
we found the lady in the one instance
and you know we kind of offered to buy
it off and we offered to buy the free
well see so so you're driving down
newport where you live you see a house
that looks like a wreck no one knows who
the owner is it's just been abandoned
and then you get a private detective you
hunt down who owns it and then you say
hey you approach them and you say this
property is absent
clearly you have no interest in it and
you strike a deal yeah because sometimes
in some scenarios they're on a 999 year
lease right with a one pound peppercorn
payment so
40 years is 40 quid
so we'll offer
you know substantially more than that
for
to buy the freehold which then could
potentially make
that deal maybe a block of flats or
whatever or a mixed-use property stack
and then you've got an exit so this
business really is about solving
problems
about finding properties that have got
problems and then you solve the problem
and you've got some incredible stories
of some of the problems that you've
solved talk me through some problems
that you've solved um
so there was i i took a call from a from
a friend of mine on social media there
were there was a
dispute with the neighbors
and kind of wanted a quick sale
so we kind of stepped in and said look
this is this is deal on the table i
think we spent about
possibly two hours on the deal we were
able to come to a conclusion for the
purchase price
um they moved on quickly out of the way
of the problem and yeah we've kind of so
this this person then wants to sell
their house but doesn't want to have the
hassle of an estate agent that's great
wants to get rid of it quickly then
maybe spot your car yeah a car your
packaged car which by the way is
hilarious um packaged packaged you
bought the car for the sole purpose of
packaging it up in a we buy houses quick
for cash yeah um
so so basically then to be a millionaire
you need to become somebody that can
solve problems find people with problems
find properties with problems have the
skill to solve the problem buy the
property use bridging finance use other
people's money buy it fix the property
fix the problem solve the problem then
refinance pull your money out and find
another problem so you're a full-time
problem solver yes yes i'd say so and as
as you kind of you know you add to your
power team as such you then
um
start solving more complex problems yes
and then add in value just by doing
paperwork so an example
um
the one block we visited today bought
that in one block and we chopped it up
into individual titles which added value
and then it's also about navigating one
thing we found with the refinances for
example
on the last year when brexit and the
elections were on
i was advised to
have the value done after the election
results so we were due to have a
valuation
just before the results were going to be
announced
um and one of our mentors kind of said
look let's
delay it and have the refund have the
the valuation done afterwards because
there's a bit of uncertainty within the
market so i didn't i kind of said yeah
okay i'll go with that and then
the election result landed we had the
valuation and
we achieved what we wanted
it's about knowing timing areas
navigating through things and i think
it's really important you talk a lot
about i mean i know you're a massive
advocate for education you spent a
portion of your money when you refinance
the house on education you join the
academy
panel of mentors training sessions and
everything
what why do you think
education and power team and mentors why
is that such an important part of
becoming a millionaire in business
because
i i haven't got all the answers
there's only you know there's only so
much you i was learning right from the
scratch i never owned a business before
i was always an employee
um
so i knew i needed to draw on on
experience and support from other people
yeah but i also wanted to know a bit
myself yeah i also wanted to learn right
you know to make sure that things were
going in the right direction and i
wasn't going into a completely blind i
know i'm not saying i'm an expert in any
of the fields yeah that you know we kind
of talk about but like i said i do know
a little bit about each one
um and i kind of
see myself as the person that makes just
puts the bits together yeah in the right
order so the properties you're buying
commercial residential mixed use
flats got a nice team now millionaire
what was it that made you
what made you agree to come and do this
interview i mean you're now a
millionaire what why why come back and
give up half hour of your life to do
this
credit where credit's due i wanted to
say thank you i wanted um you know
if anyone picks up any kind of
uh nuggets from it
brilliant i hope you know and i helped
someone else on their journey fantastic
but for me it was credit my credit stu
um
and just kind of
giving a bit back i suppose
well i really appreciate you giving your
time up and i think that it's really
easy sometimes a lot of people they
become successful and then they just
forget where it started forget where
they came from so i appreciate you
coming on the channel um and also credit
requests give to you you've worked super
hard great guy i know we've done
business together and you've introduced
me to some great people i've introduced
you to some great people we've become
friends so um you know massive respect
i'm really excited about seeing what
happens next and no doubt in another
year or two we'll do a part three when
jamie higgs becomes a multi-millionaire
i hope so
welcome brother thank you very much
thank you guys i hope you enjoyed that
interview jamie one of the most amazing
people you'll ever meet deserves
everything that he's got and i hope you
found it useful him coming back on the
channel to talk about exactly 80z how
he's done it not just all the good stuff
but some of the hardships as well
becoming a millionaire is not easy but
as jamie said with the right commitment
determination and training anybody can
do it if you'd like to come down to the
property millionaire intensive you know
what tickets on the house i'll leave a
link in the description don't forget to
drop a comment or a question in the
comments i'm sure jamie will be reading
the comments and answering i'll leave
details for jamie's website as well if
you want to connect with jamie do it
he's in newport south wales thanks for
watching subscribe see you next time
you